[Music]
just a few short months
prior to the league of legends season 2
world championships
south korea acquired a server to start
playing one of the world's
biggest esports since then the region
has dominated the competitive scene
korea
sets the meta they iterate on it and
they style
in 1v1 situations they're smarter
faster and better and everyone knows it
there's an indisputable gap a
representative from south korea has won
every world championship since season
two
that is until now
as worlds 2018 approached korea looked
primed to defend their reputation
on home soil and despite chinese
juggernaut rng
looking strong kt rolster still boasted
one of the most lethal korean rosters
in recent memory sk telecom t1 and the
god of korean league
faker were nowhere in sight but that
familiar feeling remained
the feeling of lost hope that despite
proven rosters
from the rest of the world korea would
find a way to win
they'd pummel our hopes of an exciting
storyline the gap would hold
and the rest of the world would be left
wondering what they could have done
differently
but this year something was different
after kingzone dragon x's lackluster lck
summer performance
and griffin's loss in the gauntlet korea
ended up sending
gen g the afrika freaks and the
aforementioned kt rolster
to worlds gen g bombed out of groups
going one in five
they lost both games to vitality and rng
and went one-on-one with cloud9 as
vitality absolutely turns and shocking
off
qv won't be making it too far as he goes
down a double kill for kikis
their tendency to play for the late game
was thwarted early and
often by teams that were looking to go
for the threat joined as well
and watch out as the ming is going to
walk backwards now into cuba slowed
towards the top backwards blue as well
comes down to bison's face a big ton
for xiaohu and they'll pick down ruler
look for another kill as crown tries to
reinforce but core jh will be shut down
first
three versus four in the re-engage and a
nice lantern brings them to safety mlxg
will keep running and now uzi wants to
come back in will not be stunned
will not land but they might knock down
haru he's flashless he has no roads out
five to one rng kt rolster looked strong
during groups
and were the one korean team that looked
as unstoppable as usual
that said they did take a loss to edward
gaming china's third seed
meanwhile africa also made it out of
their group in first place
but even after the first group stage it
seemed like this worlds
might be different like a cinderella
story
was possible quarterfinals began with a
series most analysts did not expect to
be close to go kt
rolster 3-1 all right deficient what are
you thinking i got kt as well i almost
put 3-0 but then i saw ig will get at
least two games on red side i figured
they might win one of them
and chad do you fall in line i think
this is an incredibly tough series to
call right now i have kt winning at 3-2
kt rolster faced off against chinese
representative invictus gaming
to kick off the bracket stage what
followed was one of the most back and
forth series we've ever seen at worlds
in classic korean fashion they wanted to
use team fighting stars like galio and
kaiser to survive lane
and grind ig into dust going late
but the likes of rookie the shy and
jackie love
had other ideas they wanted to take it
straight to kt
the roster many thought of as favorites
they wanted to pick lane dominant
champions and kill their foes early
and often rookie gonna defend this one
two versus three so far gonna be taking
you cow very very low seat if they can
maybe find the kill instead they're
gonna find the damage down instead onto
mata
kill number one going over to ig you
count gonna be taken very low charmed up
run down double kill
over the side of it fix this gaming
looking to make it even more and they
strike
back that's huge for ig score was
on the top side getting that rift herald
and they strike so quickly the shot
it's rookie zoning away the rest of kt
score's gonna be taken low shut down
the shy finds his man as rookie goes
invulnerable
and kt heads for the hills that's gonna
be chased down by the shy
the damage pours through but he's gonna
be outplayed for now
can the shy even find this it's yukow
buying some time for the other four
members
deft and bottom of trying to survive but
over the wall comes brookie
say hello to invictus gaming it's five
versus one
barely half alive the shy keeping mata
in the fountain
the turret nearly gone jackie loves
going up into the ultimate gonna be kept
alive for now
charmed down onto smith damage coming
through death's already dead
ning makes sure of that one and jackie
goes unstoppable
it's a double kill for ig's jungler it's
a slaughter for invictus gaming
kt is wiped off the map and the nexus
will join
the game they're going for two
objectives but speaking of leads
meanwhile
you have collapsed on by three different
members and tries to hold on the ball
flash away from you cal wants to stay
alive mata and death coming in with the
top catching missile voice she's not
going to be taken very low saved by
bottom with a wonderful devourer
as balance now trying to keep his
teammates alive as ning barely gets
himself out of the wall but the charge
will take him down and death makes him
this is gonna be your game ending push
one way or the other it's kt going for
the base
it's gonna be a base race next is turn
number one take another half hp
kt looking to end it right here right
now ning taken down to half it's shivers
the snap
same time it's gonna be taken very low
you cal barely gonna be kept alive score
taken out of one corner specially gonna
be killed now as well
jab take it so low the flamethrower is
not able to find him death goes to the
killing spree
it's the shy still in the base it's kt
looking to try to stand and fight if
they can
the shy has made his way onto the
inhibitor turrets on the nexus turrets
they're going to be taken down
kt still marching it's a base race
the size of the balloon excess kt's on
the red
who's gonna win the shy will not
and kt takes it to game four holy crap
there's a half on some critical members
it means it might not be as important as
it looks
shaw's going to take some damage look he
looks to go in does get the passive pop
shy's still going to be soaking room
comes down damage goes through jackie's
able to find
two jackie love just found everybody
and that's gonna be a triple for ig
they're gonna find everyone
it's kt and this time in an escape from
the storylines of the past
they would succeed 2014 they will
eliminate the korean first seed
and they will move on to the semi-finals
the korean favorite was vanquished and
on the other side of the bracket
it happened again but worse
[Music]
on a global stage maybe no region has
been more widely criticized than north
america
for years they've garnered tons of
attention heading into worlds
only to fail to live up to expectations
which makes what cloud9 did to africa
all the more historic
a clean 3-0 sweep is
this the fight it's two for zero and the
guardian angels are plucked
this could well be it look at him clean
up the map
and the last vestige of korea has been
destroyed
cloud nine will make it to the
semi-finals
a three zero sweep the first time
in seven years cloud nine
in the top four at worlds
they didn't try to play like koreans
they played cloud9 league of legends
jensen played three assassins leblanc
lisandra
and ahri while sneaky performed well on
early game carries like lucian
spence lights the route taught on a
thresh pops right away
a 3v2 in the fight as they go for the
sun and save so he will get traded
they had a plan to hit the rift and
start a bloodbath
immediately and it went off without a
hitch of the reality
the meme is dead the gap is closed
korea's not at the front in fact
they are behind the eu lcs the naocs and
the lpl
as they are fully eliminated from worlds
2018.
of course there's still much to be
learned about what exactly happened to
korea in 2018
some teams more suited to the fast-paced
worlds meta
were not in attendance like griffin and
king zone dragon x
it's not like korea has been lacking for
individual mechanics in years past
make no mistake no matter how worlds
impacts the region
this was a in korea's armor and
you can only imagine how ready korea
will be to take back their crown
in a year's time now no matter how big a
storyline korea's
collapse may be it pales in comparison
to the relative rise
of the rest of the world and for this
you have to look back to the nalcs
summer split
and the aforementioned cloud 9 roster
who at times looked quite different
than what we saw at worlds
by now you know the story cloud9 benched
their star players
in favor of rookies due to
underperformance and a lack of
motivation this is something that would
never have been considered prior to lcs
franchising this year
due to the looming threat of relegation
then they bounced back
they developed the depth of their
franchise and made a run to the finals
eventually earning their spot out worlds
in the golf ball
you're not allowed on this side this
one's for winners 3-0 tenth place to
finals is a great
story but cloud9 will do one better
10th place to world their lcs
counterparts
g2 esports and fnatic had their own
roster development albeit to a lesser
extent
in unprecedented fashion rekkles sat out
multiple games during the funnel meta in
order to put his team in the best
position to win
while blippo matured into a versatile
aggressive player
gets the 2v1 in the top lane boxes on
his way as well they might even look for
the dive oh can he get in there and at
least stop a recall then maybe flashing
for the kill
remember to shoot for max rock sir they
stopped both the recourse whipper coming
in as well cassio on her way up camp's
going to try and join this fight
could be a very early dive here from
fnatic how far he jumps in they're
trying to turn it on to grip oh he gets
one
and this goes across the box as well and
now the dive is well and truly on cap's
on his way
bucks are there to tank up the tower it
needed maxwell trying to jump around
through
the bush does turn him out of the box if
it gets taken out by cat
and so they grew they learned to play
their own
kind of league of legends not koreas or
china's or reddits
but their own then during group stages
it all started to pay off
g2 esports made it out of group a as the
second seed
cloud9 escaped the de facto group of
death in
second losing a tiebreaker to rng
and in group d fnatic won their
tiebreaker
earning themselves a first seed the west
came ready to play you saw what cloud9
did to africa in the quarterfinals but
that was topped by g2 esports's
performance against the other tournament
favorite
royal never give up the third-seeded
team from europe took it to the likes of
uzi
and rng they battled hard through a
five-game bloodbath
and similarly to cloud9 they played to
their strengths
ready to clean up the fight and this is
the best choice for rng
seeing the tv come in try to turn and
win the 4v3
for the vast majority of this oh so
so close the igniter is ticking there is
nothing perks is godlike
with the help of yarn and it went deep
now they turn their attention on to let
me he's just going to get run down the
wall
he find the lens of the answer is though
finds its mark but it doesn't matter
11 kills to one g2
they are going to do it g2 esports
leaned
hard on perks and wonder and they
trusted in karnan and wadeed
to stay alive against uzi and the bot
lane and they won
their scene just into such mechanic
creeps delivers a perfect play
g8 oh he's going to back up uzi down
it's all on xiaohu
show his money back box has found him
bird's nose
with the hourglass they may have just
done it g2 have just dismantled rng
and they're gonna make their way to the
semifinals
g2 esports will find another kill we'll
tear
open the base and busan is cheering
and screaming and crying the
underdogs reign supreme at
worlds 2018 when expectations
were at their lowest the g2 dynasty
will be defined by taking down rng
after more than half a decade of
measuring themselves up against the top
korean teams the west vanquished them in
2018.
players in the early years of their
careers like licorice whippo
zazel broxah and caps were able to
leverage
creative play patterns on high skill cap
champions
in order to overcome korea and china's
dominant rng
and with the impact of that young blood
surrounding them
the veterans of the west shaun as well
but heading into a semi-final
with three western teams some dreams
had to die
first g2 fell to ig
they took g2's game plan right to them
using their solo laners in rookie
and the shy to more or less run them
over in a 3-0 sweep
g2 may have triumphed over uzi but two
gods at once
were too much to handle wonder trying to
make something happen but g2 looks like
they just want to disengage this one now
they already got the pick on the enemy
jumper
so many people that's the antrox damage
and the shy makes it happen the shy
finds everyone there rookies still
hunting
oh rookie makes it a double kill for
himself he cleans up
perks and tragedy strikes for the eu lcs
representatives
on the other side of the bracket we saw
more of the same dominance
cloud9 may have been able to roll over
africa but fanatic
was another story cloud9 looked out
classed and
fanatic swept the na hopeful who's gonna
land
and first blood goes to broxah
they killed them early and often jumping
forward his caps
he's got the chain as well what a play
and three kills fnatic are destroying
cloud nine right now
for the west will be fnatic the kings of
the west the kings of europe
it's going to be fnatic looking to knock
it down in the 5v3 to get those last few
kills
a desperate engage and a shotgun on the
cap a few more seconds spot
but look at the blade collar it's
everyone dead fnatic
are the king to the west and they will
represent in the world final
the stage was set after a tournament
full of upsets there were two teams left
china versus europe fnatic versus
invictus gaming
two of the oldest orgs in professional
league of legends
in a historic final we knew that for
once it wouldn't be a south korean squad
that hoisted the trophy
but ig still had a chance to keep the
summoner's cup
in the east the teams hit the rift to
kick off the finals
it was clear that this would be a
challenge unlike any fnatic had faced
throughout the tournament
fnatic had relied not just on their solo
laners but
their entire team working together to
get to the finals
but invictus gaming solo lanes were on
another level
with rookie and the shy arguably the two
best players at their respective
positions
in the world and when it came down to
showtime
the west was no match for the east once
more
here we go the fnatic are on the board
already starting up the rift here
teleport comes in
ig not willing to let this go away
without a fight tp gonna be used by
fnatic
rookie's gonna be off to the side in the
middle goes whiffle going to be part of
the shield keeping himself alive
on the target stunned up but not brought
down just yet reckless going to be
firing from the back
but the fear goes off whiffle grabs the
kill down onto the enemy support
but can they find anything else they're
trying to get hillis on the way into the
back with jackie luck
has already found himself that mark here
as well blitzball's taken down by ning
the rift arrow goes their way as well
have won themselves another fight it's
not him they're worried about it should
be that support the emperor's divide
gonna keep the line
the double kill over the ding the
vanguard's edge
will completely cut them down baron will
be started up by fnatic
seeing ig in the bottom part of the map
we'll see if ig can respond to this
hilla song is going to be cut caught out
and the damage is more than enough
rookie grabs the freebie under him bronx
and fnatic
need to take down the baron it is going
to be ultimately secured by broxah as
rookie goes into the pit to pick up one
won't be able to find the second
shutdown over to fnatic
as now bronx is in some trouble over the
wall goes the alistar
and fnatic will be aced as jackie's in
the base
and they're looking to end it right here
fanatic they're looking for a gang they
want to make the play
on the shy but he also wants to turn
things around a lot of damage comes out
from him quickly goes into the
resurrection
200 hp again but now brought down and
nate walks into a really bad spot
he'll be taken very low but rookie comes
in to save them
the double kill's already gone over to
reckless can they find anything else
they're trying to get away but the
shutdown goes over to the side of balan
and ig
fnatic bringing the reinforcements as
hillasong tries to buy some time
caps and soaz make their way into the
fight but jackie's already dominating
rookies able to find the lockdown the
damage comes through
it's jackie love capps will be the last
man standing
but he will fall with the rest reckless
still alive but can they keep this game
up
it's an impossible defense at this point
roxanne reckless versus the world
reckless goes on a rampage but ning is
still there
pressuring onto the turret with the rest
of ig
reckless is down bronx is away ig are on
nexus the lpl has never won before
but that will change today the crownless
are finally king and infect this gaming
on your 2018. world champions
invictus gaming slaughtered fnatic in
the finals of worlds 2018.
they found leads early and often and
fnatic
were just no match for the first time in
history
china sat atop the world of league of
legends
and for rookie it was proof that his
commitment to china
hadn't been wasted that he didn't need
to play in korea
to win
[Music]
[Applause]
korea was dethroned and new heroes of
the east
were crowned there will be talk of the
131 metagame
fast games and flukes here and there
but make no mistake after 2018 league of
legends is finally
a global game a game where any team can
win
on any given day of korean dominance
chinese phenoms european ingenuity
and north american hopefuls now it's
time to see if china can defend their
crown
in 2019 as the new era of international
parody
opens a new chapter in the story of
league of legends
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button